cien Sunni Talal are preparing a meal
just like any other day in the village
of Katra but their lives changed forever
when their daughters were murdered
something is terribly amiss at home and
they feel that void in everything they
do they helped us with everything they
were good girls they were always around
they enjoyed helping out the family now
has around-the-clock police protection
because they've sought justice they've
made powerful enemies in the village the
men accused of the crime are from a
higher caste with considerable influence
locally they're now fears of revenge
attacks we have to protect the family
there have been threats against them the
police are here but for how long a year
six months how long will they protect
people like us before the girls were
raped and hanged only two photos existed
of the cousins their mothers say the
girls were intelligent and studious and
had high hopes of escaping poverty now
many more pictures of their lifeless
bodies have gone round the world somehow
the families find solace in the shocking
images the photos remind us of them many
people came here to see them when we
look at the photos together we cry and
it brings back memories
dig dig little bear the murders have
brought immense grief to the families
and many girls have even less freedom
than before because of the fear of
further violence now my daughter's have
to stay at home with me I can't take
them to work in the fields so I watch
them here see it takes us to where her
daughter was murdered three suspects are
in custody and two policemen have been
removed from the force the officers
allegedly protected the suspects because
they were members of the same
influential caste
the family says it's only because
residents blocked access to the bodies
at the mango tree until the news media
arrived that a real investigation
followed but to this day the family's
charges are being called into doubt
they've even been ordered to take
lie-detector tests the village elder
says the events here have nothing to do
with caste what people need is better
education he says perhaps even
University he believes locking women up
at home is wrong there are only men in
his circle ask women in the village and
you'll likely hear it's time for men to
change their attitude nobody wants to
listen to us women if we go to the
police they say who are you nobody
listens to us here if found guilty the
accused would face the death penalty but
no one here really believes that women's
lives are likely to change anytime soon